A lot of EDH discourse exists around the concept
of removal, and specifically around the question
of whether people should be running more
of it. In that great battle of ideas,
I fall firmly in the camp of incessantly telling
people to run more removal. I will happily be that
annoying guy. However, I also understand why this
advice might not be enjoyable to receive for a lot
of people. In conventional EDH deckbuilding,
ways to interact with your opponents often
ends up in the category of vegetables—it’s a
type of card that’s not flashy or exciting,
but that you need to include regardless. If you’re
building a cool EDH deck around a particular idea,
sloughing off deck space to spend on interaction
might feel disappointing—you’re effectively
diluting the quality of what’s happening
on your side of the board in order to set
back opponents. If this line of thinking sounds
like you, I understand that and I’m not here to
perform the role of the chiding parent telling
you that you need to grit your teeth and choke
down those vegetables. There certainly
are plenty of reasons to run more ways to
interact with opponents—the two big ones being
that it leaves you with a better rounded deck,
and it leads to more dynamic and interesting games
rather than luck-based, one-sided stomps. But no,
I don’t want to focus on that, because on some
level you probably already know that. Rather,
I want to offer an alternative vision to the
vegetables analogy: what if you could have all
the benefits of running a lot of removal, without
feeling like it’s gobbling up your deck space?
I’m going to talk about a couple methods for
accomplishing this task, and the first method
is to make the slots you’re already spending
on removal do more for you. When we look at the
most popular removal spells in the EDH format,
it’s mostly single target removal, typically
either low-cost options or all-purpose options
that can hit any target. To be clear, these
things both absolutely have their place, but they
are an entire deck slot spent removing one card.
What if there are two concerning cards on board?
What if somebody plays another one the turn after
you remove something? Running enough single target
removal for all potential targets can really tax
your deck space, and there are two alternatives
that can be comparatively compact—multi-removal,
and removal engines. Multi-removal is exactly
what it sounds like—it’s a spell that removes
multiple potential threats. Board wipes are one
example of this, but there are plenty of other
options available. Some of these are pretty
straightforward—Hull Breach can destroy both
an artifact and an enchantment, and Soul
Shatter forces each opponent to sacrifice
a hopefully-valuable creature or planeswalker.
However, as you get to higher mana costs there
are some spicier options too. Windgrace’s Judgment
can destroy each opponent’s most valuable nonland
permanent, and both Decimate and Casualties of
War are capable of blasting cards of several card
types all at once. A really cool thing about these
is that you’ll typically destroy one or two things
that are currently problems, but also a couple
things that might cause problems down the road.
A big mana rock, a utility land, or a low-level
value enchantment won’t be priority targets for
removal that can only target one thing, but being
able to clean up multiple of these at the same
time as a higher-value target can really pay off
in the long term in terms of denied advantage.
Removal engines are another way to make
your interaction suite more compact,
and these are cards that can destroy things over
time. Aura Shards is one of the most powerful
examples of this, but there are also creatures
like Royal Assassin and Trygon Predator that
can remove one permanent per turn. Removal
engines can also involve multiple cards,
and you’ll find this most often in control decks.
In my Sharuum Slide deck, the singular control
deck in my current lineup of decks, there
are only two cards in the list that could
reasonably be described as board wipes. However,
the deck frequently engages in heavy degrees of
board suppression through the usage of removal
engines—Astral Slide can recycle explosive ETBs,
including that of one of the two board wipes, and
there are also a number of ways to get control
pieces in and out of the graveyard. The deck
even has a stifle engine—what kind of goofy-ass
deck has a stifle engine in it? Other examples
of this might include a pinger paired with a
deathtouch enabler, Containment Priest paired
with a flicker engine, and Muldrotha paired
with a Fleshbag Marauder effect. In general,
these are great for conserving deck space—in a
toolbox control deck that has networks of ways to
find different cards, a small handful of removal
engines can free up a ton of deck space to go
toward counterspells, tech pieces, draw, and
other categories that might otherwise have to be
a bit leaner to fit an adequate amount of removal.
Now, I should say—in the case of both
multi-removal and removal engines,
you’re generally going to pay more mana for the
added benefits, as compared to the single-target
counterparts of these cards. And, for the
leanest, most unapologetically proactive
decks out there, that extra cost will likely be
an unacceptable downside. But not all decks fit
that description—we’ve seen low cost, all-purpose
removal become the quote-unquote staple choice,
even though plenty of decks absolutely can afford
to pay a little more mana in order to get more
out of their removal. Board wipes are the model of
this that most people are familiar with, and these
are nice but not perfect. They often destroy your
stuff as well, and another downside with them goes
back to the temporality of removal—if you purely
focus on blasting all the creatures off the board,
you’ll be safe the turn the board wipe is cast,
but a lot of decks can bounce back shockingly
quickly from a board wipe, or even mitigate it
entirely. Your opponents have been through this
before—you’re not catching some doe-eyed Timmy
off guard with the first Wrath of God he’s ever
seen in his life. This isn’t to say you need to
avoid board wipes—they’re a great option for a
lot of situations—but if you’re considering
your fourth or fifth board wipe for a deck,
maybe consider that there are other options
out there for accomplishing a similar task.
Okay, so that was the method of densifying the
part of your deck that you dedicate to removal.
The second method is to widen your removal suite,
but to make an effort to pick out removal that
blends into the rest of what your deck is doing.
This allows it to feel less space-gobbling even
as the number of removal cards in your deck
stays high. One way of doing this is picking
out cards that align with your deck’s synergies,
and this is typically easier the more general your
deck’s synergies are. One of the most general
options is card type—if you’re running a deck
based around artifacts or around instants and
sorceries, I can guarantee you that there are
a ton of options for interaction that will slot
in nicely with the synergy core of your deck.
This is similarly doable in decks that focus
around core game mechanics—there are lots of
great options for decks based around counters,
tokens, and graveyards. For a few examples of
synergistic picks, you could run Drown in
Ichor in a deck with a focus on counters,
you could run Trygon Predator in a deck
that is looking for evasive attackers,
and you could run Lethal Scheme in deck that gets
a wide board of creatures and wouldn’t mind a bit
of extra filtering. An extension of this principle
is modal cards—cards like Valorous Stance,
Silverback Elder, and Gix’s Command are solid for
both removal and non-removal purposes. There are
also plenty of cards that are effectively
modal without explicitly invoking the word
“choose”—landcycling cards like Angel of the Ruins
as well as MDFCs come to mind. The important thing
is that these cards can allow a deck to pack a
lot of removal that can be used when needed, but
not feel like its deck slots are being actively
gobbled up. This leads to more fluid gameplay,
since these cards can be lands or draw or ramp
or protection in addition to being removal. This
is also why counterspells are good if you can
afford to hold up mana without falling behind,
but this is a video about removal
spells so I’ll leave it at that.
As an example of removal blending in, my friend
Hans has a deck he likes to call Izzet Bizzet—it’s
a Lilah, Undefeated Slickshot deck that runs
as many Prophetic-Bolt-style cards as it can
possibly get its hands on—we’re talking any red
blue instant or sorcery that both deals damage
and draws cards in some capacity. As a result of
this, even though the deck is packed out the wazoo
with creature removal, since almost all of that
removal draws cards and works with the commander
as well, it feels perfectly fine. Another example
of this is my Radha deck, and that deck actually
takes advantage of both methods I’ve mentioned in
this video. For the blending in part, all of the
removal in this deck is attached to either a big
creature or a cascade spell. This is great because
those are things I want anyway—cascade spells
will usually grab me a piece of ramp to pump up
my land count, and big creatures are what I use to
pressure life totals and eventually win. This is
compounded by the density of these—a full seven of
these are one-card removal engines, and a single
one of these sticking around for multiple turns
can wildly warp the shape of a game. As a result
of these things, the deck is very much so eating
its removal vegetables, but when I play it it just
feels like a big dumb cascade ramp deck, even as
it eats opposing permanents at a healthy pace.
I’ve given a couple of nice options for fitting
more removal into a deck—densifying the existing
removal suite through multi-removal or removal
engines can let the same number of cards do more,
and blending removal into the rest of what
a deck is doing through synergistic or modal
options can similarly offer more removal in
practice without it feeling like it’s hogging
too much deck space. However putting these
options into practice requires understanding
what removal is actually doing for your
deck. Even in this, a video about removal,
I’ve so far largely abstracted away what removal
is actually accomplishing in a game, letting it
sit simply assumed that it’s a good thing to have.
So, what is removal doing? For some decks, this
is a question with a clear, specific answer—in
my Francisco Malcolm deck, a deck that fits the
lean-and-unapologetically-proactive descriptor
I mentioned earlier, removal principally exists
to kill creatures that threaten my turn 5-6 win
or that might allow opponents to win faster than
that. If I’m playing the deck and my opponents
play out some scary engine creatures on turn
4 to 5, I don’t generally need to remove these
as long as my combo is on track to end the game
before those creatures have a chance to cause
problems. For this reason, all of the deck’s
dedicated removal is 2 mana or less to allow
it to be weaved into a turn comfortably—I run
the low-cost staples because I don’t need to
care what’s happening on board two turns from
now. Similarly, I run a lot of mana-efficient,
single-target removal in my Meria deck as well
because it’s a Voltron deck—player removal is
absolutely on the table, so my removal is there
to deal with obstacles to my beatdown rather than
controlling the board. By contrast, I run removal
engines in my slower, grindier decks because the
timeframe for winning is a lot less concrete—I’ll
usually have some tools to put pressure on
opponents relatively early, but the plan to
win isn’t focused enough to be relied on as
any sort of clock to calibrate the rest of
my gameplan against. Thus, in these sorts
of decks, my removal exists to let me stay
alive and prevent opponents from winning for some
unknown duration of time, and as a result I need
to prepare for a wider range of situations and
run removal that works better in the longer term.
There will also be the question of instant
speed removal vs sorcery speed removal,
and this will come to power level above all
else. If you’re playing at higher powers where
sudden infinite combo attempts might happen, and
especially if you’re not playing blue to allow
for counterspells, instant speed removal will
likely be kind of a must. Likewise, if you’re
holding up removal at instant speed just in case,
you also want that removal to cost as little as
possible to avoid wasted mana if the removal
is unneeded. Staples are staples for a reason,
and this is basically the reason. You might even
want to include a handful of these in a slower,
mid-power deck just for the sake of
contingencies—they’re good cards,
and if you failed to slow down a player
earlier in their gameplan, having that
insurance policy to prevent a blowout can be
important. However, if you’ve already got your
first three or four single target staples, maybe
try branching out a bit from there and consider
alternatives that work better for your deck in
particular. Your deck will likely thank you.